how many subscribers this Lord DIY I
have just under 8.5 million subscribers
Blood Sweat and Tears for the last 10
years is how we came to be at 8.5
million subscribers but I mean it's been
10 years and I've been pretty
consistently uploading like a video a
week for 10 years with like a mental
breakdown scheduled on like a quarterly
basis so there's been a few breaks but
for the most part it's been 10 years of
making consistent videos how many
tattoos does Lord DIY have Mom this is a
great time to skip ahead in the video I
think I have 14 now I've got a 73 Vega
here my dad has one and it's been like a
family thing that's been in our family
forever I got my Japanese beta name here
and then this is a cootie catcher
there's absolutely no meaning behind it
I just thought it was cute